we've been waiting for you all this time
little did you know it would be me hey
I'm Nick Jonas I'm here BuzzFeed and
today we're having a staring contest we
got some ground rules first person to
blink loses talking or trash-talking is
allowed but most importantly no one
knows they're having a staring contest
with me let's do this
smells like somebody famous Oh
[Music]
how are you I don't know if you know
this but I was like now oh my god okay
gambling welcome I bling-bling so fast
oh my god okay three two
they told me to look at your nose your
eyes are really wide I'm drying them out
and you busy do you do a mustache
sometimes was it always the beard
sometimes you just got to mix it up
[Laughter]
hello like your nails we've been waiting
for you all this time
little did you know it would be me I'm
crying well done thank you well done you
push myself to the limit that's what I
was thinking how are you today
it's so hard not to blame I felt your
pain all time I practiced all day hey
well done up where the opponent yeah
yeah that was a lot of fun obviously
some very memorable moments for me
and for maybe them see you next time
[Music]